[Музика]
привіт, мене звуть Ольга, місячна мама, і
ласкаво просимо на сьогоднішній урок, тому що я
маю це в руках, зрозуміло,
давайте поговоримо про те, про що
сьогодні всі говорять, про те, що
має великий вплив  у житті кожного
громадянина цієї планети він
змінив наш спосіб роботи, живий спілкування, подорожі, подорожі,
це змінило все,
наше життя ніколи не буде таким, як ви,
мабуть, здогадуєтеся, що ми будемо говорити про
коронавірус або жадаємо 19, як це
називається  все почалося в грудні 2019 року в
китайському містечку Вау, давайте подивимося
на карту, там є багато джерел
інформації щодо covin 19, але
одне, якому я довіряю, і те, яке я пропоную
всім використовувати та перевіряти оновлення,
це Всесвітня організація охорони здоров’я так
подивіться на веб-сайт, я
перевірив інформацію вчора, і, як ви
побачите, у всьому світі понад 4 мільйони
4000 підтверджених випадків
і рівень смертності, як ви побачите на
цьому сайті United S  Тейт має найбільшу
кількість заражених людей, тоді як
Росія, а потім Великобританія ідуть
за країнами з найкращими та
найбільш розвиненими економістами, які
намагаються боротися з цією хворобою, оскільки в
Україні в один день цього
великого травня їх понад 500 28
випадків, зареєстрованих за один день,
загальна кількість хворих на цю
хворобу в Україні становить понад 17 000
шокуючих новин, але від вас і
від нас залежить зупинити поширення хвороби,
коли ми дивимося новини,
ми чуємо нове слово про цю хворобу  і
це називається пандемією, давайте подивимося,
і інформація, яку я передаю з
Вікіпедії, розповідаючи нам, що це за
епідемія, є епідемією хвороби
, яка поширилася на великий регіон,
наприклад, на кілька континентів або в
усьому світі, впливаючи на значну
кількість людей у всьому св
ті  історія була низка пандемій
хвороб, найсмертельнішою пандемією в
зареєстрованій історії була також чорна
смерть  відомий як пробка, яка вбила
приблизно від 75 до 200 мільйонів людей
у 14 столітті, ін
і помітні пандемії включають па
демію грипу 1918 року або іспанський грип, як ми зн
ємо, нинішні пандемії включають ВІ
/СНІД і охоплюють 19 давайте по
лянемо на текст ще ра
Ви побачите чотири відсутніх слова, які
Карен розповсюдила та включила, прочитайте
текст самостійно та спробуйте зіставити слова
з відсутніми частинами в тексті
[Музика]
[Музика
] пандемія тепер на екрані ви можете
побачити текст із
я сподіваюся, що вам вдалося це зробити добре, тепер
ви знаєте, що таке пандемія в
усьому світі, і вона швидко зростає
[Музика]
ця хвороба не тільки змінила наше
життя, але й принесла новий словниковий запас
у наше життя, якщо ми говоримо в  терміни
англійської мови давайте подивимося на
деякі слова, які ми зараз чуємо в
новинах, носимо їх у статтях, ми бачимо
їх на інфографіці про
хворобу походження, звідки
хвороба походить від хвороби  себе
спалах, щоб запобігти заходам безпеки
підтверджений випадок поверхневе перенесення
вразливе поширення є іменником і
розповсюджувати як дієслово, ці слова ми
будемо мати сьогодні в тексті, чи буде він
у відео, і я впевнений, що ви знову використовуєте
їх у повсякденному житті  сучасне життя,
на жаль, у всіх нас є запитання
щодо цієї хвороби, у нас будуть запитання
щодо цієї пандемії. Я пропоную всім
подивитися чудове відео, створене OVH О,
це відповідає на деякі питання
питання номер один – наскільки заразна
ця хвороба питання номер два, що
таке  симптоми цього питання №
3, як запобігти його
поширенню, і останнє, і, мабуть,
найважливіше, як нам залишатися в
безпеці, коли я кажу, що ми маємо на увазі вас і мене
вашу сім'ю ваших друзів ваших
бабусь і дідусів суспільство всю країну
нації та всіх громадян нашої
землі в грудні 2019 року
в Китаї виникла група випадків пневмонії,
розслідування показало, що вона була
викликана раніше невідомим вірусом  Зараз він
називається новим коронавірусом 2019 року в цьому відео,
ми швидко подивимося на те, що
зараз відомо про вірус, майте на
увазі, що це новий вірус, і те, що
відомо про атмосферу
зараз може змінитися в майбутньому,
коронавіруси є великою групою
вірусів, вони складаються з ядра
генетичного матеріалу, оточеного
оболонкою з білковими шипами, що надає
йому вигляд корони, а
латинською назвою Corona і ось як
ці віруси отримали свою назву, існують
різні типи коронавірусів, які
викликають респіраторні та  іноді
шлунково-кишкові симптоми респіраторні
захворювання можуть варіюватися від звичайної застуди
до пневмонії, і у більшості людей
симптоми, як правило, помірні, однак
є деякі типи коронавірусів, які
можуть викликати важкі захворювання,
зокрема тяжкий гострий респіраторний синдром,
коронавірус, вперше виявлений в Китаї в
2003 році.  і коронавірус респіраторного синдрому Близького Сходу,
який вперше був
виявлений в Саудівській Аравії в 2012 році,
201  9 нового коронавірусу вперше було
виявлено в Китаї, він спочатку
виник у групи людей з
пневмонією, які були пов’язані з
ринком морепродуктів і живих тварин в
місті Ухань, з тих пір хвороба
поширилася від тих, хто був хворий, на
інших, включаючи членів сім’ї.  і
медичний персонал наразі є багато випадків
, і хвороба поширилася
в Китаї, а також у ряді
інших країн, тому звідки взявся вірус
, відомо, що коронавіруси
циркулюють у різних тварин,
іноді ці віруси можуть зробити
стрибок  від тварин до людей це
називається переливанням і може бути пов'язано з
рядом факторів, таких як мутації
у вірусі або посилення контакту між
людьми і тваринами, наприклад, Murska v,
як відомо, передається від верблюдів,
а Tsarskoe V від циветт.
Резервуар нового коронавірусу 2019 року
поки невідомо, як він
передається, точна динаміка способу
передачі вірусу ще не
визначена.  n Загальні респіраторні
віруси зазвичай передаються
повітряно-крапельним шляхом, коли інфікована людина
кашляє або чхає, або через щось,
що було заражено
вірусом, люди, яким найбільше загрожує
зараження новим коронавірусом, це ті, хто знаходиться в
тісному контакті з тваринами, наприклад,
працівники ринку живих тварин.
і ті, хто доглядає за людьми,
інфікованими вірусом, такими як
члени сім'ї або медичні працівники, то
як добре протікає хвороба з того,
що відомо на даний момент, може бути ряд
симптомів, від легких до важких
, може бути лихоманка та респіраторні
такі симптоми, як кашель задишка,
у більш важких випадках була
пневмонія, ниркова недостатність і смерть, рівень
смертності ще не відомий, як
ми можемо визначити, чи інфікована людина,
інфекцію можна діагностувати за допомогою тесту
під назвою ПЛР або полімеразної ланцюгової реакції, яку
цей тест ідентифікує  вірус, заснований на
його генетичному відбитку пальця, на
даний момент не існує специфічних ліків для цього
вірус і лікування є підтримуючою терапією
. Наразі немає вакцини для захисту
від вірусу лікування, і
вакцини розробляються, як запобігти
передачі вірусу, цей новий вірус
зараз має обмежене географічне
поширення, однак існує ряд
стандартних гігієнічних заходів, які
були  Рекомендується для захисту від
інфекції та подальшого поширення,
наприклад, прикривати рот і ніс
під час кашлю або чхання серветкою медичної
маски або зігнутим ліктем, уникати
тісного контакту з
хворими належним чином використовувати маски та засоби
індивідуального захисту, особливо
в медичних закладах, умивання
регулярно терти руки водою з милом або
спиртом.
Заходи, які можна вжити, щоб запобігти
зараженню від тваринного джерела, включають
уникнення непотрібного незахищеного контакту
з тваринами, миття рук після контакту
з тваринами або продуктами тваринного походження та
забезпечення ретельної обробки продуктів тваринного походження
перед їх  ви споживаєте це
Важливо залишатися вдома, якщо ви
погано себе почуваєте, але якщо у вас гарячка, кашель і
утруднене дихання, зверніться за медичною допомогою
якомога раніше та поділіться історією попередніх подорожей
зі своїм лікарем
, це швидкий огляд цієї нової
інфекційної хвороби, враховуючи цей
спалах  швидко розвивається те, що
відомо про цей вірус, може змінитися,
будь ласка, перевірте веб-сайти нижче,
щоб знайти найновішу інформацію правильно
дякуємо за перегляд востаннє подивіться на наші
запитання,
тож наскільки заразною є ця хвороба, спробуйте
відповісти на запитання самі спробуйте
використовуйте словниковий запас, який я запропонував
раніше заразний так, як ви можете
легко підібрати його номер два,
які симптоми хвороби, давайте
подивимося на інфографіку, що показує
основні симптоми Kabat 19 номер один
сухий і безперервний кашель номер два
гарячка, де  Ваші груди або спина відчувають гарячу
втому номер три, а номер чотири
– симптоми, схожі на грип, біль у горлі
та нежить, коли ви бачите ці
симптоми у вас ваша сім'я ваш друг
дотримуйтесь порад зв'яжіться з лікарем
уникайте відразу в лікарню
використовуйте номер телефону абонента
опишіть ваші симптоми лікар
порадить вам, чи потрібно вам відвідати
лікарню, щоб записатися на прийом,
чи лікарі прийдуть  і до зустрічі
, давайте повернемося до питання номер
3 із відео, яке ми бачили, як
запобігти його поширенню, оскільки ви
бачите, що правила прості, ми всі
залишимося вдома, тому радимо нам
дотримуватися, ми повинні захистити себе від
підхопити хворобу та не
передати її іншим, що легко
зробити, звичайно, носіть маску, коли
ви спілкуєтесь з іншими людьми, дотримуйтесь
соціальної дистанції, яка становить принаймні
півтора метра, і не забудьте
стерилізувати поверхні, яких ви торкаєтеся,
і що  багато людей торкаються в громадських
місцях, тому це те, що ми маємо в 2020 році,
це те, що ми ніколи раніше не використовували
в таких великих кількостях, але
це прості правила
ми повинні дотримуватися, щоб запобігти поширенню хвороби,
і останнє питання, яке ми
всі задаємо собі, і ми
шукаємо відповідь, як нам убезпечити
лікарі не знають дослідники не
знають найбагатші країни на цій
планеті  не знаю, давайте залишатися в безпеці,
дотримуючись правил, які ми чуємо кожен
день, залишаючись вдома, захищаючи
вразливих, у нашому випадку вразливими
є літні люди та вагітні
люди та найважливіші інші
лікарі та медсестри, які піклуються
про людей, які  охопили всіх
тих, хто має інші захворювання, але перебуває в
небезпеці через відсутність медичного
персоналу та обладнання. Дотримуймося
простих правил, щоб запобігти
поширенню та убезпечити себе. Пропоную
прочитати текст і, прочитавши його,
згадати про цікаве  техніка,
яку я використовую в особистому житті під час
викладання, і коли мене просять зробити
презентацію або виступити на публічному заході,
це називається навчи вчитися, коли ти
збираєшся читати те  xt візьміть аркуш
паперу, ручку чи олівець і
занотуйте найважливіші речі,
як захистити себе від
вірусу. Техніка навчити вчитися - це коли
ви читаєте, коли ви вчитеся,
коли ви щось слухаєте
пам'ятаєте  що згодом вас можуть попросити
навчити когось цієї інформації я впевнений,
що кожен із вас зможе поширити цю
інформацію та захистити свою родину своїх
друзів та всіх українців давайте
разом прочитаємо текст
зверніть увагу на підкреслені слова
вони допоможуть вам
пізніше написати  ваша власна історія ваш власний текст,
який має бути планом, нехай це буде
інфографіка або повідомлення, які ви будете
розповсюджувати в пізнішому коді 19 - це інфекційна
хвороба, спричинена вірусом корони, який
вперше поширюється від людини до людини
через краплі, що утворюються, коли
інфікована людина говорить, кашляє або чхає,
ці краплі повинні
рухатися в повітрі лише
приблизно на один метр і
швидко схоплюватися  Це
є причиною поширення від людини до людини.
Пошта між тісними контактами, точний
час, коли вірус може вижити,
ще невідомий, тому має бути розумним регулярно очищати
поверхні, зокрема наші
руки торкаються багатьох поверхонь, які можуть бути
забруднені  Тому з вірусом вам слід
уникати торкання очей, носа,
рота, оскільки заражені руки можуть
перенести вірус з поверхні до
себе під час кашлю або чхання, прикривайте
рот і ніс пов’язкою
ліктя або використовуйте одноразову серветку, коли
використовується серветка.
найефективніший
спосіб запобігти поширенню нового коронавірусу
– це часто мити
руки спиртовмісною рідиною для рук або
водою з милом, це усуне вірус,
якщо він знаходиться на ваших руках, залишайтеся здоровими та
запобігти поширенню corvid 19 зараз я
пропоную вам не тільки попрацювати над
текстом, чому б вам не зробити відео, а
навчити свою сім’ю, друзів та інших людей,
lobe, як запобігти
поширенню, порада проста, чому тримайтеся
на відстані між вами та людиною, з якою
ви розмовляєте, коли ви кашляєте, чхайте,
будь ласка, якщо ви можете використовувати
одноразову серветку серветку, яку ви
викинули відразу після використання або
відразу після вас  використовуйте це, використовуйте закриті
контейнери для одноразових серветок, якщо у вас
немає серветки під рукою, використовуйте
лікоть, зігніть його, і ви можете кашляти або
чхати. Залишайтеся вдома - це ще одне
найважливіше повідомлення для всіх нас, яке ви не
тільки можете вловити  хвороба, яку ви можете
легко поширити, доторкнувшись до
поверхонь, як ми бачили на відео
раніше, краплі потрапляють на
поверхні, якщо ви не продезінфікуєте їх, вона
залишається там, і дослідження ще не
знає відповіді на те, як довго це  залишається
там, незалежно від того, чи це 10 днів 2 тижні або
довше, маска
захищає вас, але пам’ятайте, що існують
правила, як її одягати та як знімати.
Я носив цю маску
три години, і мені пора
поміняйте її, перш ніж я зможу зняти маску
з обличчя. Спершу потрібно продезінфікувати
руки я можу потім не торкатися
обличчя зніміть маску і покладіть її в
одноразовий контейнер, щоб вона більше не
поширювала вірус, давайте подивимося і
використання обкладинки з тексту, який я
пропоную вам використовувати у своїх відео або інфографіці для своїх розповідей,
все, що ви вирішите
створити, викликане в основному через
краплі, приблизно осідають на
поверхнях, поширюються виживають забруднені
уникайте негайного торкання одноразової тканини,
щоб запобігти поширенню
часто ліквідувати вірус
на початку я не згадав,
наскільки Кааба 19 змінила наше життя,
давайте подивимося на перший аспект,
перший і найважливіший для мене
- це соціальне дистанціювання, яке ми
повинні залишатися вдома, правила це
змінився спосіб спілкування,
давайте подивимося на це зображення
маски один читає один від одного немає
вечірок немає групових зборів соціальне
дистанціювання нове слово фразу
у нашому словнику давайте поглянемо на
це світло, що змінилося в освіті
учні учні батьки вчителі тепер
усі стали експертами в онлайн-
навчанні о так, мій семирічний син
має онлайн-уроки моя донька веде
уроки онлайн я викладаю онлайн мої
колеги  викладати онлайн – це не дивно,
розчаровує
обидва розваги. Я не впевнений, що ми
раніше звертали увагу на те, наскільки
важливо для нас зібратися разом,
щоб мати можливість піти в кіно чи
театр, чи на концерт, чи на шоу, тепер
це змінилося  дивитись концерти
лінія ми ходимо в мій музей ми
дивимося драми онлайн я вдячний
усім артистам усім виконавцям, які
дають нам можливість дивитися їхні
шоу онлайн на екрані ви можете побачити,
як робляться ці концерти
Пандемія Ковача змінила те, як ми подорожуємо
, змінила спосіб роботи транспорту.
Громадський транспорт перестав
працювати, і він не працює в
Києві вже близько двох місяців, усі
рейси скасовані  скасовано всі
кордони закриті, ми всі сподіваємося
повернутися до нормального життя, але давайте
дотримуватимемося простих правил, щоб це запрацювало
світова економіка постраждала як від величезних
транснаціональних компаній, так і від малого
бізнесу, наприклад, кафе, ресторанів,
готелів
так, будемо сподіватися повернутися до  звичайне
життя, будемо сподіватися, що всі підприємства
повернуться до роботи, і ми зможемо
насолоджуватися їхніми послугами, і вони зможуть
продовжувати заробляти гроші для своїх
сімей і бізнесу на розвиток
corvid 19 всюди, де він використовується,
говорять діти  про те, що
бабуся й дідусь говорять про це ми говоримо
про це з моїми колегами,
багато джерел інформації, я сподіваюся, що
ви вивчили корисну лексику,
яка дозволить вам
повідомити, що ви думаєте про Корбетта,
вашу думку про те, як це
зупинити  Ви працюєте над
дослідженням, або як його зупинити,
є багато різних джерел
інформації щодо охоплених 19,
але я б довіряв одному, поки
Всесвітня організація охорони здоров’я ви завжди можете
перейти на веб-сайт, переглянути останні оновлення,
переглянути останні відео про те, як запобігти
його поширенню, як зберегти безпеку, і,
як ви бачили на попередньому екрані,
ви також можете дізнатися, що відбувається
не тільки всі  у всьому світі, але й в
Україні залишайтеся вдома, будьте
здорові, будемо сподіватися, що ми ніколи не
зіткнемося з чимось таким поганим, як Кобі 19
[Музика]
ти